free nazanin free nazanin free nazinee
for five years calls for the release of
nasalin zagari ratcliffe
went unheeded free nazanin
finally on sunday her ankle tag was
removed
she has spent four years in prison and
almost won under house arrest
but it's unclear if she will be allowed
to travel back to the uk
the british foreign secretary while
welcoming the developments
called iran's treatment of her
intolerable
a dual iranian uk citizen she'd gone to
iran with a young daughter
in april 2016 to visit her parents
on the day she was meant to travel back
to the uk nasanin was apprehended
by members of the iranian revolutionary
guard at tehran airport
in a secret trial zagari radcliffe was
sentenced to five years in prison
on charges of plotting to overthrow the
iranian government
allegations which she and her family
have denied since then
her legal team says she has been
subjected to solitary confinement
blindfold interrogations and carried out
hunger strikes
given kind of the sensitivities around
this case even kind of the media
interest
that in this case the islamic republic
sees this
effectively as an opportunity it sees it
kind of as a
bargaining chip to be able to kind of
put more pressure certainly on britain
in order to get kind of more
advantageous in spring last year she was
eventually placed under house arrest
at a parent's home in tehran because of
the coronavirus pandemic
throughout her husband richard has been
leading the campaign for a release
and throughout it all their daughter
gabriella
counting the days until her mother would
be free
priyanka gupta al-jazeera